good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you're very welcome to the
breakfast show here on sky news
terrible news this morning global
leaders condemning the growing evidence
of civilian killings and war crimes in
ukraine hundreds of bodies were found in
towns
outside kiev after russia retreated some
buried in mass graves ukraine's
president described russian forces as
murderous torturous rapists and looters
western nations are moving to impose
more sanctions speaking to a cabinet
minister in the next few moments
it is monday the 4th of april
the prime minister boris johnson accuses
russia of despicable attacks against
innocent civilians in ukraine
i'm in lev in western ukraine as
prosecutors gather evidence about
civilian deaths with some bodies found
with bound arms and feet and some signs
of torture
also ahead reports that fines have been
issued to downing street staff who
parted on the eve of prince philip's
funeral last april
easyjet cancels more than 60 flights
because of staff shortages caused by
covert
[Applause]
john baptiste wins album of the year at
last night's grammys will bring you all
the results
coming up on the program for you this
morning
[Music]
we'll chat to a pair of directors as
part of skye's unearthed narratives
initiative aimed at increasing black
representation on our screens
[Applause]
i'm swapping dancing shoes for running
shoes we'll speak to aj and curtis
pritchard after they ran a half marathon
to raise money for the chelsea and
westminster burns unit
[Music]
hello everybody global leaders have
condemned the growing evidence of
civilian deaths and war crimes committed
by russian forces in ukraine hundreds of
bodies were discovered after russia
retreated from the outskirts of the
capital kiev some with their hands tied
behind their backs
the uk has said it will support an
investigation at the international
criminal court
the allegations center on the town of
buca which is 34 miles from the center
of kiev as well as the areas around
hostimal airport and urban which saw
fierce fighting in the early days of the
war
images from buchar appeared to show
bodies piled up in a trench
around 45 feet long which was dug into
the grounds of a church where a mass
grave has been identified russia has
denied targeting civilians and described
the pictures as a staged performance by
ukraine
but president zielenski accused them of
genocide
hundreds of people killed tortured
executed civilians bodies on the streets
booby-trapped areas even the bodies of
the dead are booby-trapped widespread
aftermath of looting
concentrated evil has visited our land
executioners rapists marauders who call
themselves an army and who deserve only
death after what they've done
well our international affairs editor
dominic waghorn is uh standing by in la
viv for us in western ukraine uh the
images on most of the front pages of the
newspapers this morning uh dominic's
absolutely shocking stuff
that's right came it's a weekend in
which the ukrainians have turned the
tide of war against the russians but the
scenes that the russians have left
behind are absolutely appalling grisly
grim scenes of massacre carnage rape and
looting and total devastation ukrainians
say they've recovered 410 bodies so far
in the villages and towns around kiev
140 of which they've examined already
looking for signs of war crimes
gathering evidence and they've found
bodies that have been bound
tied hand and foot uh civilians
slaughtered in the streets as the
russians left the area and they found
these mass graves as well to the east
they say they've also retaken the
ukrainians have also taken parts of
chernohev but the mayor of that town
says 70 percent of chenohev has been uh
destroyed and there's a lot of concern
also about the
officials that the russians have
kidnapped abducted 11 mayors and other
officials are being held by the russians
so concerned about their welfare i think
ukrainian's concern is now that the the
shift of military center of gravity for
the russians has shifted to the east
they have pulled out completely from
kiev even out of chernobyl to the north
across the border into belarus but they
are expected to focus their fire now on
the donbass region and the governor of
donetsk the ukrainian government donetsk
is urging people to get out of there to
evacuate bracing themselves
for for what could be to come so to kind
of pause in the fighting as the
ukrainians discover what the russians
have left behind and then brace
themselves for what could be coming in
the east yeah um we're hearing uh that
the brits are very keen to consider some
of these actions as a war crime um what
more support do we know that there is
for that and also we believe that russia
are looking to to get the u.n security
council in emergency session what's that
about
i think the russians want to have an
emergency session the security council
to put their version of events across
which so far um has been completely
unconvincing the russians say that uh
that not a single civilian uh was hurt
in their occupation of the area around
uh kiev their version of events is that
as they left civilians were protected
and what we've seen clearly from our
cameras and many others on the ground
and from what ukrainians are saying is
that the russians seem to have
deliberately sought out civilians and
slaughtered them as they were on the
side of the street and as they left
these areas so the russians have a lot
of convincing to do in terms of what the
british can do and what the west can do
the ukrainians clearly want to have
support in gathering evidence of war
crimes but they also want to have a lot
more military support
and they say that their weapons supplies
are dwindling because the resistance is
being very fierce against the russians
they need to be rearmed they don't want
just want anti-tank missiles they want
anti-aircraft systems they also want
fighter jets as well the mayor of this
town la vive told me that they need that
they also need the west to take
seriously giving up russian oil and gas
immediately and they say there's no
point in these sanctions being imposed
on russia
if billions of euros are handed over to
the russians every day in return for oil
and gas because that money is simply
going to be used to fund the re-arming
of the russian military and they're
completely convinced that this is far
from over that the russians are in for
the long haul and therefore they need to
prepare for what could be a months-long
campaign and they need to be re-armed
for that and the russians need to have
as few resources for their re-arming as
possible they say okay don for now thank
you
well there has as you were saying been
international condemnation to the
reporting of what happened in burka
boris johnson condemned russia in the
strongest terms saying russia's
despicable attacks against innocent
civilians in urban and bukha are yet
more evidence that putin and his army
are committing war crimes in ukraine he
went on to say the uk has been at the
forefront of supporting the
international criminal courts
investigation into atrocities committed
in ukraine we will not rest until
justice is served
and united nations chief antonio
gutierrez has called for an independent
investigation saying he's deeply shocked
by the images of civilians killed in
buca
the polish foreign ministry says the
images and atrocities carried out can be
compared to the darkest times of
stalinist and nazi totalitarianism
but the russian ministry of defence has
denied killing civilians in the region
claiming the images are a piece of
theatre staged by ukrainians government
and the western media
well the world secretary simon hearts
with us now hi mr hart thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
i'm sure you've seen the images on the
front pages of the papers
what we going to do about it i mean it's
it's as you said it just seems to be
completely unbelievable i think you have
to look twice blink twice to be able to
actually fully take in
uh what's happening i think what we've
got to do is as some of the reports have
indicated to keep the pressure on in
every way we can whether that's in the
provision of weapons whether it's in the
provision of financial help all of the
different ways in which we can and have
so far intervened we must continue to do
and if anything we need to step that up
sanctions likewise there's a history
sometimes of sanctionings weakening over
a period of time so now isn't the moment
to sit back and say we've done enough uh
we've provided all the help we can let's
just see what happens actually now what
we need to step that up and continue
also to do what uh president zielinski
has i think praised us for doing which
is leading the international response to
this so i think there's a load of other
stuff that we can should and in many
cases are actually okay let's unpack
that military aid what's that what does
that look like
well i think we've seen what it looks
like so far it's provided
it's provided well it's providing the
kind of uh defensive weaponry that we
have already done in greater numbers i
have to be careful what i say this is
very much ben wallace in the pm's area
of
responsibility indeed absolutely no so
i'm not ducking that um and so it's
increasing as far as it is reasonable to
do so um uh all of the aid that we've so
far given all sort of weaponry so so far
given but also making sure that when
when uh ukraine comes to us says
actually we need a slightly nuanced
version that we need a different sort of
defensive weapon to make sure if we can
if we physically can we possibly can we
either provide the financial support or
the actual sport to be able to provide
that and i think so far okay you know
we're leading the world in that we will
continue to do so and but it it's a as
we've seen
overnight
rather sort of graphically this is a
very fast-changing situation so we are
very much uh watching this on an
hour-by-hour basis okay odessa is a port
that is incredibly important
to ukraine of course for all sorts of
reasons they're asking for um anti-ship
missiles sunny times reporting yesterday
the prime minister wants to provide them
with that how far along the line are we
with that
well i think we've heard what the pm
said yesterday uh it clearly is
something we're considering yeah
absolutely i mean he said so he wants to
be able to help as far as that's
concerned uh and and those these are the
judgments which he and others are making
but it's not this is not just the uk
this is about leading a world response
if the response is to be effective it
needs uh the west and many many nations
to come together in that common endeavor
so it is better that we make sure that
we take everybody with us that's what
we're trying to and that is indeed what
president zielenski has praised the uk
for doing which is actually leading this
global
effort okay
we've seen people
with their hands tied behind their backs
shot in the head not once not twice many
many many times
quite rightly people are fleeing that 11
000 people want to come or have applied
to come to wales from ukraine will 11
000 people be allowed to come i mean
we and welsh government this is one of
those areas where there is more than one
sort of responsible body are determined
uh to live up to our reputation of being
a nation of sanctuary uh we want to make
it as easy as possible we want to make
it as quick as possible that do need to
be inevitably they do need to be
checks of some i hope limited nature
just to make sure that everybody's safe
in that process but absolutely there
should be no you know
those images that you've just described
ought to remind anybody or everybody
who's looking at this and we haven't got
uh the time to uh to sort of you know
naval gaze over this we have to get on
with it i think we are doing a i think a
reasonable job we can always do more we
can always go further we can always go
faster but
letting people in the country so far my
question is will the eleven thousand
ukrainians ten thousand ukrainians who
want to come to
wales be allowed to come yeah i hope so
it's a matter of welsh government as i
say but uh we're working with them very
closely we want that to happen
there shouldn't be there shouldn't in a
sense be any uh limits to this we should
be responding to need so why is it
taking so long well this is always i
i would love to be able to i would love
to be able to come here i would love to
be able to come here and and and say
that we can just flick our things and
everything would happen in states i
think most people rather are sometimes
some practical ones who are trying to
keep the bureaucracy to an absolute
minimum
and welsh government let me just say
minister this it's 38 days since ukraine
went to war we know what the russians
are capable of given what happened in
syria we knew even before they went to
war that it was likely that's what the
foreign secretary sat there and told me
time after time so why have we still
only allowed a handful of ukrainians
into the country i think that's
i think that's a bit harsh right we've
already approved 25 000 uh visas i don't
think that's happening
to me that that doesn't seem to be a
handful i think it's we're working we're
working with trying to make sure that as
far as my area of responsibility uh is
wales is as open and available
immediately uh that's if already there
are families arriving well we want more
we want to respond to uh to demand and
respond to need cause as i say by the
images that we've seen we don't want to
we're not here to stand in the way of
any of that and just
sit there with a clipboard saying no we
actually want to move heaven and earth
to make sure that we get people into
wales safely
for as long as they need to stay in
order
how many families are already in wales
well we've committed at the moment uh
we've we've got an open-ended commitment
so how many we've got
that's a question you have to ask welsh
government no but you did say that
they've already arrived yeah they have
there are families arriving there are
families in my own constituency i can't
tell you how many across ireland wells
this is an ever-changing picture um and
it's a matter of welsh government to
answer that specific question all i'm
saying um is that we are literally
trying to make sure that everybody who
needs to come everybody who wants to
come
can come because
as i said there is no reason there is no
reason at all why we would want to slow
why would we want to switch let's move
on and talk about kobe do if we make
because we have a limited amount of time
this morning um
we're just reading in the papers this
morning that uh the office for national
statistics i think it was offstead
forgive me saying that a generation of
babies and toddlers struggling to crawl
and communicate as a result of lockdowns
uh enforced by this government how do
you think
history will judge this government when
it comes to young people i think the uh
the covert inquiry will do a number of
things as far as i'm concerned the
sooner it concludes better so i think
what it will show is that some of the
decisions which have been taken over the
last couple of years which people have
been highly critical of have actually
been very sensible decisions in the very
rapidly changing circumstances where we
were learning as we went along and i
think that when we look back and did we
go into lockdown too soon too late what
were the considerations what was the
effect on uh kids education and life
chances i think that is where we will
learn some
very frank lessons as far as i'm
concerned i think that both welsh
government in my case and or in the case
of wells and uk government in the wider
context i think actually will be judged
better than sometimes
people give them credit for because we
ratted very fast to a very rapidly
changing situation we did everything we
could at the time to protect the economy
as well as protecting public health some
of those decisions will have been
correct some of those decisions you know
when we look back over two or three
years we may have made differently i
think all of them whether you're mark
drakeford sat in cardiff or whether
you're
you're me sat here uh in westminster all
of those decisions were taken with
public health uh in mind and the
protection of public health if we didn't
get them all right yeah i think the
inquiry
will reveal that
wait for the inquiry um as far as
partygate is concerned of course the
people in charge of those decisions that
you've been illustrating there have
started to receive fines um including um
helen mcnamara deputy cabinet secretary
then deputy cabinet secretary
um who was basically in charge of ethics
for the government at the time she had a
karaoke machine in her office it was
used at one of these parties she's
received a fine
karaoke at downing street at the same
time that people were being told they
couldn't sing in church does that sit
comfortably with you of course it
doesn't sit comfortably with anybody um
and the pm is on numerous occasions come
out and said um how bit how bitterly he
regrets uh the circumstances which led
up to the most of course it doesn't i
don't barely a day goes by when i don't
look back and wish i did some something
different when i look back over two
years and look at every decision i made
every judgement i made i speak the other
side look back and think actually could
we've done that differently could we
have done that better did we no no
minister these people were responsible
for policy and they were partying and
being told that you can't sing in church
and they they were all taking turns on
the karaoke machine yeah i i said you
asked me if i that sat comfortably and i
gave you a very frank answer of course
it doesn't of course it doesn't
why should it well indeed should the
prime minister resign if he's fined
well i i take a very clear view of this
which is based on well i'll tell you
what i have 65 000 constituents in west
wales where i represent and they are not
shy and coming forward and expressing
your view about this a number of other
subjects and
throughout all of this saga of the
downing street parties they have said
one thing very clearly and in a vast
majority is they want contrition and
they want an apology but they don't want
a resignation and i actually think at
the moment the idea given what we
started this conversation talking about
the idea that we might it might be
appropriate to have a sort of six-week
self-indulgent leadership context and
the contest a little bit frankly i don't
think that's very sensible either as
i've said before we all make uh
judgments which we have time to reflect
on and wish we'd made differently uh i
think for me personally speaking i think
uh the world's moved on as considerable
distance i trust the views of the people
who elected me in in
saying that look put this problem right
make sure you apologize you know you
you acted inappropriately at the time uh
and uh but the idea that uh every
politician or indeed every journalist
for that matter who makes a misjudgment
along the way should automatically be
sacked is not something i subscribe to
they do it time and time and time again
well wait and see secretary of state
thank you very much indeed thank you
let's have a look at what's happening as
far as the front pages are concerned
this morning russia has been branded
worse than isis by ukraine's foreign
ministry as evidence of mass graves and
public executions were discovered by
ukrainian soldiers in the town of buca
that's on the front of the metro this
morning
horror in bucha says the guardian as
russian troops are said to have tortured
and killed civilians the times says
russia has been accused of genocide
after schools of bodies were found in
the town on the outskirts of kiev
and that's also on the front of the mail
which says the russian retreat has
echoes of the second world war
still to come on the program for you
this morning talking all things ukraine
and partygate with the shadow education
secretary bridget phillips and that's
just after eight
speaking to a defence and security
expert following reports of civilians
killing and signs of mass graves in
towns outside the ukrainian capital of
kiev
and a little later we'll speak to a
ukrainian woman who's waiting for her uk
visa and her best friend who started a
hunger strike here in protest
of the lengthy application process
in other news the hong kong leader
carrie lam has announced that she won't
be seeking a second term in office
in 2019 and 2020 there were huge
protests involving hundreds of thousands
of people demanding greater democracy
let's find out more should we tom
standing by for us in beijing this
morning is this a surprise tom good
morning
it is a bit of a surprise though some
people who thought she might tough it
out but she has presided over perhaps
the most tumultuous period since hong
kong was handed over by the uk to china
in 1997. as you say those protests in
2019 the imposition of a sweeping
national security law and then the
handling of kovid 90 and she did play a
pivotal role in all of those especially
those protests despite how violent they
ended up they started as these mass
peaceful marches and what people were
asking for was the junking of an
extraditional proposed extradition law
between hong kong and china
carrie lam refused to budge on that she
relied on the police instead and they
morphed into these very very violent
protests we saw instead and that led to
that imposition by beijing of this
national security law which uh western
countries say has diminished hong kong's
traditional freedoms it's led to
sanctions uh led to a souring of
relations uh in hong kong and then the
last
event really was covered 19 hong kong
shut itself off from the world
it bought itself a lot of time it kept
the infections low it kept covered at
bay but recently its most recent wave
has led to a very high daily death rate
scenes of parents being separated from
their children because of the
territory's strict covert 19 policies so
that hasn't been handled well and it's
required more intervention from the
mainland as a result of all that put
together hong kong has lost a lot of its
luster as an international business hub
because of those restrictions singapore
seems to be more or less back to normal
while hong kong is still struggling as
well as a brain drain really of local
and expat workers who don't want to put
up with that anymore whether that's
because of the security law and because
of those restrictions on the other hand
hong kong is a lot tighter in beijing's
control now and you think beijing and
perhaps carrie lam herself will be
pretty happy with her outcome
let's look at some of today's other
headlines for you know um hungary's
prime minister viktor orban has won a
fourth consecutive term in office he
defeated a coalition of six opposition
parties which had united to try to
remove him from power
[Music]
a new report setting out steps to tackle
the climate crisis is due to be released
the latest findings from the un's
science body is expected to recommend
actions required to curb global warming
and identify alternatives to fossil
fuels
police in california are searching for
at least two people in connection with a
drive-by shooting in which six people
lost their lives twelve others were
injured in the attack which happened in
downtown sacramento in the early hours
of sunday morning
investigators are working to identify
those responsible for this horrific act
we know that a large fight took place
just prior to the shootings and we have
confirmed that there are multiple
shooters
investigators are currently interviewing
numerous witnesses
to take you back to ukraine should we
global leaders have condemned growing
evidence of civilian killings in ukraine
as hundreds of bodies and signs of mass
graves were found in towns just outside
kiev joining us now is the former
director general of the royal united
services institute and defense and
secure security analyst and that's uh
professor michael clark hello t
professor thanks for joining us on the
program this morning
we've been looking at those images on
our front pages today
of what looks like a massacre
as the russian troops withdraw is there
any
strategic benefit to carrying out a
massacre like this
no no whatsoever the the deliberate
targeting of civilians is a war crime in
and of itself every day of the week
so um unless somebody can provide a
military logic why civilians are
targeted then that is a straight war
crime and civilians who appear to have
had their hands tied behind their back
and were shot
is there's no other there's no strategic
rationale for that whatsoever and what
it reflects is the probably the
activities of the rosvaria who are the
uh the the internal police of like the
gestapo who moved in with the russian
troops and were rounding people up
according to lists and so some of these
killings might have been uh as well as
examples to the villagers or revenge but
a lot of it one suspects is troops uh
out of control
because russian troops famously have a
very um low level of ncos the sergeants
the corporals the sergeant majors the
the non-commissioned officers who are
there to keep the troops in order and
are there to lead their troops and keep
them keep their battle skills ready
their drills and skills as they call it
and their behavior those are the people
who are in control of the the behavior
of young soldiers on the ground
and that core of ncos in the russian
army as it was in the red army is very
very weak and so part of this looks like
a classic case of russian soldiers out
of control working just in their own
little friendship groups who probably
got angry and uh very vengeful uh
because the people opposed them and
people as well came out to uh to to
indicate that they were going to go
about their normal lives
putin says they're being set up he says
this is not the case and he's calling
for an emergency session of the un
security council
they always deny it the russians deny
everything like this they go through
three phases first of all they deny
everything
and then they try to obfuscate they
create stuff on social media which
indicates all very complicated and this
was going on at the time and that was
going on and no simple answers are
possible
and then a couple of years later they
often admit it and they say yes yes we
did do this or we did do that but you do
the same and they point to some sort of
moral equivalence in the west they did
it over uh the poisoning of litvinenko
in 2006 and skripal in 2018 they did it
over the the bringing down of civilian
airliners uh civilian airliner over
ukraine uh in 24 to 2013 2014 um they
always deny it they always do and nobody
believes them that's the point when
western intelligence agencies speak
particularly the british intelligence
agencies when we say to the rest of the
world we have the evidence generally
speaking the rest of the world believes
us
what happens with countries like china
and india and syria when they see images
like the ones we've seen on our front
pages today does it still
does it still cement their support
of russia although i suppose you could
say china has not come out as forcefully
as that but they certainly are still
sitting on the fence or does it make
their support waiver
it's a very good point kay the um
the fact is in china we don't know that
they will see these images because the
press is so tightly controlled
the elite will because china doesn't
care if the elite sees western material
as long as most people don't
but it will make it very difficult for
countries like india or brazil or
pakistan all of which are sitting on the
fence and the countries in the gulf
because they do have a more free press
not very free but more free
and these images will filter through to
most people so it will become
increasingly difficult for the the
strong men leaders around the world who
at the moment are trying not to commit
themselves against putin it'll make it
very difficult for their own
political standing to seem to be
complicit in what is becoming an ever
more disgraceful war how it will affect
xi jinping in china we're not sure he
has a very personal commitment to putin
um he believes in putin and he's not a
very flexible man people around xi
jinping are really quite pragmatic but
he isn't he's inflexible so it will
become more difficult for all of them
including china but probably a more slow
process in china for them to feel that
this is a war in which they really do
have to take sides and the western
powers are making it very clear this
week more than ever that this is a war
in which you cannot be neutral on a base
a matter of basic morality sooner or
later you're going to have to take sides
i thought before we let you go professor
the elite fighting force that was the
russian army or led to believe it was
the russian army doesn't seem to be
in force in ukraine as we speak and
they're moving away from the capital
city kiev or the
main cities as well
there must be concerns though about the
port city of odessa
yes um it looked as if the the russians
have been beaten clearly in kiev they've
given up on on trying to take care for
the time being
we thought they probably tried to take
uh to to give up on taking odessa
because they're not making much progress
they've they're even further away from
mikolayev than they were last week so
they're being pushed away from odessa
not towards it
however um if they're going to re-uh
organize and try to move into the
southeast of the country in the donbass
region and then push this land bridge
all the way across the southern coast of
of ukraine all the way through crimea to
odessa then that maybe that that will
become part of the strategic
requirement again and we might see a a a
renewed attempt to take odessa but i
have to say they're still quite a long
way from doing that and i think that the
russians will find that they've got a
pretty tough fight in the donbass
because they'll be up against the best
of the ukrainian forces who are all
concentrated and as they have been for
the last eight years in that
southeastern part of the country
okay professor always good to talk to
you and get your perspective thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you
what's happening as far as the weather's
concerned
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
milder and more unsettled over the next
few days but colder air isn't far away
and likely to return to the north later
in the week
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well in what's been a harrowing 24 hours
for news coming out of ukraine here is a
small sliver of light among the darkness
for you jax put these pictures together
for you today uh this man filmed himself
make a very special evacuation from the
country of the only family of tapers in
the whole of ukraine to have had babies
i know
he saved them from the feldman eco park
in kharkiv nestling them with hay in the
back of his van
they look pretty happy well maybe not
that one uh to certainly be uh finding
themselves a new home
hello everybody a very good morning to
you welcome to the breakfast show here
on sky news this monday morning let's
bring you today's top story should we
russia has been accused of genocide
after hundreds of bodies were discovered
in the town of buca some were found
bound and shot
it's reported that fines have been
issued to people who attended a party at
downing street the night before the duke
of edinburgh's funeral last year
and travel chaos erupts the country's
busiest airports after easyjet canceled
more than 200 flights over the weekend
due to staff shortages
let's get more on that story should we
now standing by for us at gatwick this
morning is uh katie um hi um katie a lot
of people will be wanting to get away
from this weather uh but uh proving a
little bit more difficult if they've
chosen easies yet
absolutely not ideal okay for people
wanting to get away for the easter break
now easyjet say they've had to cancel 62
additional flights today uh that's inc
that's it
can you hear me kay so i can casey i'm
sorry i don't know why
they have easy jets
no sorry i lost you there for a second
so easyjet says they've cancelled 62
flights today that's in addition to 200
flights that have been cancelled over
the weekend that's because of staff
shortages they say due to uh covert due
to
the impact of staffing being off sick
with covert they did say they tried to
mitigate the impact of this
somewhat by rostering additional staff
on across the weekend but they have been
forced to cancel these additional
flights which easyjet have said
this morning uh they say uh they have
tried to focus the cancellations on
routes uh with lots of flights so people
are able to rebook hopefully uh the same
day but that's not what a lot of
passengers have been saying a lot of
passengers have been saying that they've
ended up being stranded their flights
have been cancelled with just hours to
spare and they were offered no
alternatives now of course this is in
addition to problems across airports
across the uk we've had issues at
heathrow as well yesterday lots of
passengers
having an extremely long queues there
and they said uh that was because of
high passenger volumes that they weren't
uh necessarily prepared for also
manchester airport have said uh they
have also experienced staff shortages
due to coronavirus again so a lot of
issues with people trying to get away
for the easter holidays and disruption
expected to continue later into this
week
okay thank you thanks a lot
well the independence travel edition
simon calder standing by for us this
morning hi um simon what on earth is
happening
well we've got uh yet more cancellations
here as well british airways i'm
counting about 90 cancellations to and
from heathrow its main base of course um
it's pretty much the same problems as
easyjet is facing there's a kind of a
temporary uh serious problem with the
sheer number of uh people who've got
cobias you've been reporting and that
means that an awful lot of crew are sick
that explains why we've had not just
cancellations that were notified maybe a
couple of days even a couple of weeks in
advance we've had a whole slew of
cancellations of british airway flights
overnight as well um that is kind of on
top of the more profound chronic problem
which is that you can jet british
airways and heathrow airport gatwick
manchester edinburgh bristol belfast
they've all let great staff go over the
past couple of years when aviation
almost closed down and unfortunately you
cannot just switch back on
that amount of people that amount of
expertise they've got to be trained
they've got to be security cleared and
wow there's a huge demand for people
wanting to travel for an awful lot of
families of course it's the first
holiday they've been able to have for a
couple of years and unfortunately the
airlines can't cope really crucially
we were hearing about passengers not
being repulsed it is absolutely clear if
your flight is cancelled then the
airline is obliged to book you on the
next available flight doesn't matter if
they've got to buy a business class
ticket on a different airline that's
what they need to do to get you to your
destination they also need to pay you
cash compensation and of course if you
need to stay overnight they will be
booking your hotel and paying for your
meals that's absolutely strict liability
and they can't get around it i'm hearing
very sadly the number of passengers
saying that they're not delivering that
um the airlines say oh yes we do so
as long as you know what your rights are
you can try to insist on them
yeah it doesn't stop spoiling your
holiday though um does it um what's
happening at manchester airport
okay manchester's got pretty chronic
problems of course the biggest uh
airport in the whole of the north of
britain um
just behind heathrow and gatwick in
terms of passenger numbers and well
again they haven't got the security
staff um there's big problems and they
tried to open terminal one attempt three
that hasn't happened so just very very
long queues where i flying out of um
manchester or stansted already i think i
would invest four thousand five 5 or 6
000 respectively in fast track security
and to try to avoid those problems um it
has been really bad over the weekend it
should be a little bit easier at the
moment but i'm afraid as with so much in
travel you can hope for the best years
to holidays but be prepared for delays
and disruption
okay for now thanks very much indeed
simon thank you blustery up there at
heathrow as well this morning not as bad
as as it gets trust me thank you simon
now global leaders have condemned the
growing evidence of civilian killings
and war crimes in ukraine hundreds of
bodies were found in towns outside kiev
after russia retreated some buried in
mass graves earlier i spoke to the
cabinet minister simon hart and asked
him
despite the condemnations what will the
uk do to stop events like this happening
again
i think what we've got to do is as some
of the reports have indicated to keep
the pressure on in every way we can
whether that's in the provision of
weapons whether it's in the provision of
financial help all of the different ways
in which we can and have so far
intervened we must continue to do and if
anything we need to step that up
sanctions likewise there's a history
sometimes of sanctionings weakening over
a period of time so now isn't the moment
to sit back and say we've done enough uh
we've provided all the help we can
let's just see what happens actually now
what we need to step that up and
continue also to do what uh president
zielinski has i think praised us for
doing which is leading the international
response to this
well i also spoke to the defense and
security analyst professor michael clark
who said the images come out of ukraine
show
a war crime has been committed
the the deliberate targeting of
civilians is a war crime in and of
itself every day of the week
so um unless somebody can provide a
military logic why civilians are
targeted
then that is a straight war crime and
civilians who appear to have had their
hands tied behind their back and were
shot um is there's no other there's no
strategic rationale for that whatsoever
ali is here with us this morning good
morning good morning uh what did you
make what the minister had to say
morning kay well i think you know he has
joined in the international condemnation
there's no doubt the images we're seeing
are completely shocking mounting
evidence of atrocities in the towns
where russian troops are pulling back
we know um that
tomorrow we've got the un security
council meeting president zielenski says
at that meeting they're going to be
talking about war crimes we know we've
seen um a united response from western
allies um saying that they want to work
with the international criminal courts
to make sure that people are prosecuted
for war crimes if that has happened um
but we heard him there i think you know
being strong but what president
zielenski wants to see is further
military assistance and i think we've
got a clear indication we know that
britain were very fast
at the start of the war with helping
with military assistance a clear
indication i think he gave you that they
will be going further he said increasing
as far as it's reasonable to do so he
was um he wouldn't really be drawn on
the specifics but he did confirm the
speculation that we've seen the last few
days about anti-ship
missiles which would help in odessa
which is a key strategic port in the
south of the country so he confirmed
that to you this morning so it does
sound like we are going to see further
military assistance of course the other
question is how far will europe go with
sanctions particularly on energy and
that is something that president
zielenski has been pushing for as well
okay you're with us at nine o'clock
aren't you for your take uh look forward
to it for now ali thanks very much
indeed thank you well the government's
under increasing pressure to speed up
the visa scheme for ukrainians fleeing
the war with russia and to take in more
refugees
joining us now our best friends
christina coniak and rend platings uh
rend is here in the uk and christina is
still waiting to join her family um
hello to you both christina first of all
um
tell us what's going on
um
i think you all can see it through the
pictures
you receive from here from bucha from
european uh i i think they are pretty
talkative they
speak for themselves
that's what is happening the war is
happening
um okay meantime in cambridge you're
waiting to offer a home
uh you registered i think i'm writing
saying as soon as you were able to
what's happened since
so not very much we've just had an
acknowledgement um and
we haven't heard anything about a visa
or how long it's going to take
so um we're sitting here kind of
anxiously waiting i mean we hear it it's
a bit random some people are getting
visas maybe but um
we've been waiting a very long time and
christina's in ukraine
um
and there's still no visa so
we are anxious about it
christina tell me about your
circumstances tell me what's happened to
you
um i live in kiev
this is my home city
and i stayed uh during the first two
weeks
i stayed at home with my with my parents
actually and my grandpa who is 18 89
years old
and then um
well we were pretty afraid and
my parents were unsure about leaving
well they have their age and it's not
that easy for them to
give it all up
and in the end i i decided to to leave
through pain
and tears and
to leave them behind
and now i'm in the western part of
ukraine um
my brother's family is nearby here
i try to go and see them if i can
like once a week or so and my parents
are still in kiev with my grandpa
and that's the our personal situation
rend um tell us how you know about
christina's plight and what made you
want to help her
she's my friend so um she's one of my
best friends if not my best friend
and we um
met at a restaurant some years ago in
kev and just hit it off and last um
december we even went to antalya
together and it feels like an age away
us sort of enjoying our wine in antalya
doesn't it christina feels like an age
away from what what's what's happened
here and then the shock of what's
happened um has affected you know
obviously christina and her family but
all of us and all of us close to people
in ukraine and also people who are
um just
normal english citizens british citizens
who are wanting to help and it's just
such a shame that so many people want to
help but we're not being allowed to help
them because the government is being so
slow on this visa scheme
and that's why
sorry that's why i'm on the fourth day
of my hunger strike if you were going to
ask about that because i'm i'm pretty
sure wait a second to ask about that
because i wanted to ask christina again
if i if i may and then i was going to
come back to you and if i may um
christina
when you leave your family behind and
you
i can't even begin to imagine the
process that you must have had to go
through in order to think i need to
leave them behind in order to try to get
to the uk at any stage did you realize
that it was going to be so hard
um
again i didn't talk about it
of course and
and then my home
my lovely home
i'm so sorry
you know you say that material stuff is
not important but then if if it's a real
life
i actually
was hugging my walls when when i
realized that i had to leave and my
furniture
like my my stuff that may seem a bit
stupid but
when you realize that you may never see
it again
and then
my parents
what can i say
so sorry
don't be sorry don't be sorry at all i
know that you know i was going to make
the point that that ren feels so
strongly about it that uh rent you do
tell us more about your decision
to go on hunger strike until the british
government does something to help your
friend and and others like christina i
should say it's not just
pulling her application out of the
bottom of the pile but it's it's just
that we need to do more and we need to
get these people here and i
spoke a bit with my husband about it and
um
also we ended up chatting to our
daughter who's eight years old and
explained how you don't do this just
because you don't get a new toy or
something like this this is a serious
thing
for you know a serious protest for a
serious um
uh thing and that you agree with your
family and you talk to people about it
and you know so we decided we planned it
and we decided that i would i decided
that i would do it
and um i'm on the fourth day now
and you know it's not been that easy and
people have been very concerned you know
looking at me and saying oh you know how
are you feeling and you know you haven't
had any food for four days but you know
whenever i get hungry i just think of
the people in mariupol and then that
solves it actually for me because i'm
very lucky here because even though i
have no food i'm drinking water and i um
you know it's nothing compared to what
people experience experiencing over
there not just you know fear of
loss of food or loss of food but also
maybe you know bombings as well and
utter devastation and loss of loved ones
i mean it's nothing what i'm
experiencing here now doing this protest
is nothing compared to what's happening
now in ukraine and the devastating
images that you see
now uh you know these are people's homes
you know these are these are
belongings things that they're close to
these are people's families you know
when you're removed from the situation
you don't see it in the same way but
when it's someone close to you you can't
you can't stop but worrying worry about
them so that's why i'm doing this and
what do you want the british government
to do ren that they're not doing at the
moment i want them to process these
visas really quickly i mean christina's
visa was applied for on the 18th of
march and it's still not come through
there are reports of people's visas not
having been um ish having been issued
and then them not being told i mean what
is going on you know what are we trying
to do here the british government needs
to get behind the the generosity that's
been shown by the british public and
they need to back that back their
rhetoric up with actual actions we need
to see these visas being issued quickly
for people in this desperate situation
christina do you still have hope that
you will be able to reach the uk
i really have hope
that i can be back soon because it's
basically it's the only the only place i
want to be now is
my home my parents
so
actually this is my greatest hope
uh but then yeah i understand that
may not happen
any soon now
and i really think that
somehow maybe i can be
more useful there
helping my people uh like i i teach i
teach
languages so maybe i can be helpful some
somehow
maybe i can help with uh with ukrainian
kids because i know that like many
mothers
left a
alone with their kids they don't have
any help so
i'm good with kids uh i i actually have
some like
a small plan of action how i may help
so
um this is my
major motivation
to try and be helpful
for my people
um so yeah
i am i'm ready to leave for that
but yeah to tell you the truth i would
rather be heading home okay
thank you both for taking the time to
join us hopefully you'll be reunited
before too long um we appreciate you
uh being so honest and forthright this
morning thank you both
thank you thank you